this is a major police operation to find
those who try to assassinate their
colleague
often seen leading press conferences
this is detective Chief Inspector John
Caldwell a senior and well-respected
murder Detective
thus follows the results of the
postmortem
after coaching in under 15 football team
at this Sports Complex he was putting
footballs into his car when he was
attacked and shot multiple times by two
gunmen in front of his young son
dozens of other children were present
they ran terrified for cover as the
attackers fled the investigation quickly
focused on the new Ira three men were
arrested today as John Caldwell's
colleagues paid tributes he has a credit
to his family and to the Police Service
and of course our thoughts are with John
and his family as he fights for his life
in hospital today John Caldwell is a
past people of oma high school and
around 15 young pupils from the school
witnessed his attempted murder some were
just meters away when gunfire erupted
some kids were obviously shocked still
shocked and they they were they looked
numb and they didn't know what to say
they are worried about him and his
health and how he is coping in hospital
there is pupils in the background that
are crying and they're very emotional
about what happened last night and they
cannot cope the school is no stranger to
tragedy five pupils here died in the Oma
bombing it's sheer luck more names
aren't being added to the memorial that
heinous attack on John Caldwell last
night involved not just Jon but also our
children so those people showed no
humanity and they attacked our children
it was the Secretary of State said a
cowardly and callous attack everybody in
the police and community and actually
the community of Omar is completely
shocked by this because Society has
moved on in Northern Ireland there is no
place for violence like this
condemnation 2 from across the local
political divide there's no support for
violence here within the local Omar or
kiliklahar area
as we're looking for a brighter and
better future ahead someone who was
liked and respected by the all of the
community entire community in this area
and I think that is why that you have so
much anger and outrage DCI Caldwell
investigated the dissident murder of
this colleague grown in care more than a
decade ago he told reporters that no one
deserves to be murdered because of how
they earn their living those that seek
to drag Northern Ireland back to a
darker time sought to do just that
Stephen Murphy Sky News
Oma